[Musique]
pour le paiement par chèque qui me faut
deux pièces d'identité
son fameux travailler ici elle est morte
dans un accident de voiture il ya six
mois par un braquage
il voit l'esprit de flouze dernière fois
que tu me dis ça j'ai fait un moteur
sert beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et c'est
quoi le flanc pendant la braderie le fac
sur la tempe
il crache le b
en simple filles on décroche vient
m'aider la valise kosar misère on
aimerait bien avoir ces play by sais qui
je suis
[Musique]
pourquoi
bon et nous fait un très vieux
[Musique]
c'était pas là dans 20 minutes tu
trouves front après je m'occupe de tout
et ont donc eu l'écho pin kung a
décroché un gros fric encore meetic ont
fermement joueur le plus mandali rival a
buté
[Musique]
le décès des photos devant l'afflux
question je vois
j'ai toujours su que tu pouvais tirer
désormais genre
un jour ton a du sang sur les mains
peut que le faire marche arrière
[Musique]